you
what is going on everybody welcome to
the third eller force index tutorial
video and last video we were programming
it in Python this video are actually
going to plot it up in matplotlib so if
you didn't already get the sample code
that we're going to plug this into it's
right here the link is in the
description go ahead and copy all of it
and just paste that into an empty file
we scroll up a little bit this is where
we're going to paste the new code so if
you go over to your other script I just
left them on here besides this highlight
from here all the way up to the
definition of EF I copy that come over
here paste it and then fix the indent
with a co it's going to take two indents
and now what we want to do is actually
plot this stuff so let me make it big
now that we're typing so now we have
that X and ry so graphing it is pretty
basic from here it's just going to be a
simple a x2 dot plot and we're in plot
efi x efi why and we're going to plot it
in white also will do plot dot y label
and the label that we're going to give
it is an EFI 14 and the color we're
going to give it is a white save that
will run that asks us what stock to plot
will plot something new will do X on
spits out everything we could probably
silence that anyway here's X on oh which
right through our minus SP let me do
that real quick and we'll stop it from
printing out the eller force index and
here we're going to add minus SP that's
just minus that makes it start at a
starting point you want two more about
that and while we're doing that check
out the Python charting stocks tutorial
series and you'll learn about that
otherwise nuts plot another wants to
yahoo
oh that spike is quite displayed for efi
this one's a pretty rough efi so anyway
you can see a really spikes here uh-huh
with the like drops down and shoots back
up again and drop stance some more good
stuff anyway so I see eller force index
has taps too well about the other force
index then had a program and then how to
plot it so hopefully you guys have
enjoyed hopefully you learned something
new as always thanks for watching thanks
for all the support of subscriptions
until next time